[Música]
como lo hemos venido comentando a lo
largo de nuestros informativos de hoy
Joe biden aspira un nuevo mandato en la
casa blanca el presidente realizó su
anuncio esta mañana a través de un video
publicado en las redes sociales en él
hizo énfasis en los desafíos que
enfrenta el país como las políticas
conservadoras que han acabado Por
ejemplo con los derechos reproductivos
de las mujeres según sus propias
palabras su compañera de Fórmula seguirá
siendo la actual vicepresidenta camala
Harris vamos a conversar sobre este tema
y para ello saludamos en Júpiter Florida
Estados Unidos a Luis de fleischman él
escopresidente del centro pom Beach para
la democracia e investigación de
políticas públicas Muchas gracias y
Bienvenido a directo a América
un placer estar aquí contigo América
este anuncio de vaivén que ya se veía
venirse en el medio de reporte de la
baja popularidad del mandatario Quiero
preguntarle si esto es contraproducente
o es una nueva oportunidad para
convencer a los estadounidenses
bueno
[Música]
es interesante porque la baja
popularidad del presidente en este
momento está dada mayormente por el tema
de
de su edad pienso que no la gente no
cree en la posibilidad de que biden esté
apto para un segundo mandato Pero no
estoy tan seguro por ejemplo de que sus
políticas sean del todo completamente
impopulares
eso es algo que se está por ver
por otro lado recordemos
que esta no es la primera vez que los
americanos van a tener que
elegir entre
candidatos digamos lo que se llama van a
tener que taparse la nariz y elegir
entonces también la cuestión es Contra
quién está compitiendo biden Y si la
percepción es que Donald Trump
posiblemente en este momento parecería
ser que Donald Trump es la persona que
representaría al partido republicano
corre Es probable que
biden gane esa elección simplemente por
el rechazo a Donald Trump que ya sucedió
no solamente en las elecciones del 2020
sino también en las elecciones
de legislativas del dos Bueno sobre eso
le iba a hablar porque justamente sobre
estas discusiones alrededor de la baja
popularidad del mandatario nos traen
esta sorpresa en las elecciones de medio
término que básicamente frenó la tan
llamada marea roja que se esperaba en el
país y esto también es dio una muestra
del rechazo al retroceso en derechos
sexuales y reproductivos que es uno de
los enfoques con los que Joe biden lanza
esta nueva campaña
Usted cree que este tema podrá ser
definitivo en las elecciones del 2024
no sé si definitivo Pero obviamente
tiene un peso y yo creo que el partido
republicano en este momento se ha dado
cuenta de que el tema del aborto les
está volviendo como un Boomerang lo
vimos por ejemplo en la en el referéndum
que tomó lugar en Kansas Kansas es un
estado conservador sin embargo el la
gente la sociedad votó en contra de una
una enmienda constitucional que hacía
del aborto algo permanentemente ilegal
entonces
Obviamente el tema del aborto es
extremadamente complicado porque no se
trata simplemente de una interpretación
religiosa o por la vida o por el Derecho
sino también hay cuestiones de salud a
veces el aborto se tiene que hacer o
llevar a cabo por una cuestión de salud
y de emergencia y por ejemplo en el caso
del estado de la Florida
prácticamente no existen excepciones
excepto digamos
violación y
insecto y tiene que haber un comité
médico Que decida si hubo incesto Y si
hubo violación o sea de la misma forma
también está restringido si el aborto es
realmente necesario para salvar la vida
de la mujer entonces todas estas cosas
Yo pienso que generan un poquito de
temor en la población Incluso en la
población republicana Entonces yo creo
que sí es un tema que es un tema que
efectivamente corre en contra de los
intereses del partido republicano pero
usted está hablando de un caso
específico y no es casualidad la Florida
donde rondesante dice cada vez se
fortalece más como un posible
precandidato pese a todo lo veíamos esta
mañana en los medios de comunicación
casi que se da por hecha una batalla
entre Joe biden y Donald Trump es un
escenario similar al de las elecciones
pasadas Usted cree que hay posibilidades
de que el republicano sea desbancado
para un eventual campaña contra Joe
biden
hablás de Trump si Trump sería
desbancado claro Sí podría por ejemplo
una figura como ron de santis ocupar el
lugar de una candidatura presidencial
para el 2024 bueno
todo es posible Siempre siempre estamos
siempre nos encontramos sorprendidos por
las circunstancias No pero en este
momento según lo que yo veo en las
encuestas y lo que todos hemos visto las
políticas de ron de Santi en Florida no
han tenido resonancia a nivel nacional y
tú acabas de mencionar el tema del
aborto justamente es uno de los temas
donde
lo hace perder puntos a rondes antes en
la competencia nacional contra contra
Donald Trump
esto es correcto hasta el momento qué va
a pasar en el futuro no sé porque hay
varias cosas que han han hecho de ron de
Santa y son candidato rezagado una es el
aborto obviamente otras son la
confrontación que él tiene con Disney
que es el segundo es el segundo
empleador más grande del estado de
Florida
todo esto ha generado temor
particularmente entre aquellos que
apoyan al sector empresarial y cuando
rondes antes se confronta con una
empresa grande
creo que
eso genera un poco de rechazo entre los
republicanos no Entonces esto es lo que
le está dando en este momento una
ventaja Donald Trump y creo que la
última vez que leí las estadísticas
estamos hablando
del 45% en favor de trampa treinta y un
por ciento en favor de de ron de santis
lo cual parecería ser que es una
diferencia importante no entonces
hablando de Trump qué es lo que tendrá
que hacer el actual mandatario para
aventajar al Magnate que de todas
maneras ha estado tratando de
capitalizar esta derrota que tuvo en las
pasadas elecciones y preparar el camino
para una nueva contienda electoral
es muy interesante lo que tú me
preguntas porque
yo no no estoy en este momento
asesorando a nadie pero hay algo muy
interesante en tu pregunta
yo biden de alguna forma
no rompió del todo con ciertas políticas
de Donald Trump definitivamente su forma
de gobernar es diferente es un
constitucionalista respeta el orden
tradicional y esto creo que le ha
devuelto la tranquilidad a muchos
ciudadanos norteamericanos
bueno como la de con parecidas a la de
Trump una por ejemplo la confrontación
con China
recordemos fue Donald Trump que dijo a
quien independizarse de China pero de
hecho era mucha retórica lo cual vaiden
también tiene una retórica un poco dura
hacia china pero a la vez vaiden pasó
por ejemplo el la legislación sobre la
producción de chips y semiconductores
lo cual es un paso muy práctico hacia la
independencia
tecnológica de China o sea la
independencia sí diría yo y hacia la
independencia económica de China
entonces
no es un primer paso nada más
Pero eso le da la ventaja a biden a
decir mira yo tú fuiste solamente
palabras y yo con los hechos verdad la
otra es también la materia de política
exterior verdad al principio biden fue
burlado por su y con y con justificación
fue criticado por su retirada de
Afganistán
lo cual hizo que Rusia subestimara biden
sin embargo biden
reaccionó una forma totalmente
inesperada luego de la invasión rusa a
Ucrania o sea
biden ha recuperado el el liderazgo de
Estados Unidos
en el mundo occidental y ciertamente de
la otan biden logró unidad en la otan
Trump logró división
Trump es una aislacionista Trump sigue
siendo un globalista o sea una persona
que cree en la función de Estados Unidos
y el rol que Estados Unidos cumple en el
mundo Trump era un amigo de Putin y
quizás sigue siendo amigo de Putin eso
en política exterior en política interna
obviamente uno lo puede criticar a biden
biden ha sido legislativamente
extremadamente efectivo yo lo compararía
incluso con lindon Johnson cuando pasó
Medicare y medicate en su momento en los
años 60 en su guerra contra la pobreza
pasó varias legislativas legislaciones
como el American Rescue plan el o sea el
plan de rescate americano el plan de la
infraestructura el plan de los chips y
los semiconductors que semiconductores
que acabo de mencionar y
la legislación sobre la reducción de la
inflación
o sea ha sido extremadamente efectivo y
ha logrado yo creo que popularidad entre
las clases populares
Hay un problema de inflación hay cierta
crisis económica que hemos visto hemos
visto la crisis de los bancos que a
propósito yo creo que biden reaccionó
muy rápido la crisis de los bancos pero
no sabemos si esto es el fin de la
crisis de los bancos O sea hay muchas
cosas que pueden jugar en contra de
biden pero creo que el tema de la edad
en este momento yo yo personalmente y
hablo de personalmente no sé cómo va a
jugar a nivel nacional Pero yo lo
descartaría porque creo que biden ha
demostrado mucha efectividad pese a su
edad si esta efectividad continúa en los
próximos cuatro años donde él terminaría
su mandato a la edad de 86
No sabría decirte
Mira Luis primero le agradezco por
responder tan rápidamente a nuestro
llamado ante un tema que surgió apenas
hace algunas horas y pues por Dejar
abierto el debate no porque a partir de
ahora lo que queda es eso conversar
acerca de lo que será la carrera por la
elección presidencial en los Estados
Unidos lo hice fleischmann
eco-presidente del centro para la
democracia de investigación de políticas
públicas que tenga una feliz jornada
Muchas gracias Un placer Gracias por tu
invitación Gracias también a nuestros
televidentes por acompañarnos y sigan
con nosotros ya volvemos con más de
directo América
[Música]